le terme de tournantes paraît
effectivement un peu problématique parce
qu'il laisse penser que nous vivrions
actuellement aujourd'hui quelque chose
de tout à fait différent de ce qui a pu
se passer
il ya plusieurs années et c'est vrai que
je pense au contraire que nous sommes
sur une pente autoritaire et qui va vers
une forme d'état policier pendant que
nous avons prises depuis déjà quelques
décennies je remonterai pas jusqu'à
clemenceau qui a pu jadis avoir des
phrases libéral étonnamment même si par
la suite il a pu être un ministre de
l'intérieur extrêmement extrêmement dur
mais nous vivons aujourd'hui je pense un
mouvement spécifique qui s'est amplifié
depuis cinq ans je pense lors de la
déclaration du premier état d'urgence
sécuritaire après les attentats du 13
novembre mais à un moment qui s'inscrit
dans une impro csu continue depuis 20 ou
30 ans d'atteintes aux libertés donc pas
un tournant aujourd'hui précisément mais
plutôt un approfondissement dents sur la
pente autoritaire et de l'état policier
[Musique]